this afternoon from local police give
people room on the road
you'll remember march 9 tow truck driver
ryan billett was killed helping a
motorist on 2 15. well
this morning billet's former employer
teamed up with nevada's department of
public safety to ask
people to change lanes and that's
especially important when you're sharing
the road with cyclists
you'll remember five were killed on u.s
95 near searchlight back in december
andrew bennett with the department of
public safety says it is on all of us to
pay attention
it comes down to accountability
responsibility and also making sure that
you're watching for the cyclists
you know i i've got kids and i always
you know you play slug bug
you just play sub cyclists you know if
you see a cyclist you you should say it
in the car
you know build the accountability and
getting used to looking for vulnerable
road users
nevada has a lot of move over laws for
people who are on the side of the road
essentially if you see someone a
bicyclist someone just helping someone
give them room